[拍手]
[音楽]
ああああああ
ここでどうやってください
これって安濃まああんまり考えないことだと思うんですよ
皆さん切る場所とか暮らす場所というのはだいたいま
仕事だったりとかをだったりとか
day
うえんでこの場所に相撲って選ぶはない程度
他の要因で選ぶことが多いと思うんです
浦和司令かなと思うんですけれどもこういうことを
結構実は考えてる人たちというか
それが僕はアートあるいは an artist
と思うんですね
ねえ
a 棟アーティストって
皆さん
あんまり直接上であったことがないかもしれないですけれども
まあてとにかく天才的な能力を持ってい
こんな凄い絵を履いてる人はあった
すごい報告をつくっているっていうのを想像する人が多いかもしれないんですけどもう
あるいはちょっとへんねんエンジンが自分の思いを形にしていると
自己表現しといっていうふうに思ったりすることが多いと思うんですけども
さあアーティストってすごく今今旬たちが入ってい
今私たちが暮らしていますがどういう状況どういうところだろうか
ことをすごく考えておきましたんですよ
a 棟まあの art っていうのが
たこれでもう少し実は社会とつながりがあるものだったり
えっ僕はまあもともと自分は学生時代
建築の設計を勉強していました
それ何でそんな行動を勉強したかというと
僕自身はまあ町のいろんな風景を見たりすることがすごくです
フラフラポリプをしちゃうんです
それで見えてくるものが苦しんでいるということをすごくしていました
そういう時まぁ面白かっております人の知恵とがちょっとした創造性
旬の知恵になるものが
はみ出しているようなパスが
例えばちっちゃな味噌があるんですけどそこになるさがいい
そう有段者に
いたを1枚買ってるだけなんだけれどもそれで急に動きが降り出してるわけです
都会の真ん中って
まあ全くもって
お庭とかモテなかったりする
けど自分家の窓の前
今の
wiki よりはい寄せて
あってしまうそういうは伊藤人の何でもない
合成面白いなと思うんだから
そういうゲームに関われるものの実は建築なんじゃないかなというふうに思って建築
寄せよく
でも実際に大学でとかい例えば構築段階に入って僕は今境になんですけれども
まあ1990年代以降
前半2割と東京で勉強してたんです
その時にまあ
東京や都市の再開発
割と大きな再開ですけど
今
東京よろしぅ前の家ですとかあるいは
道
ポン6本日ですが
2000年ない政府
でもの競技9街は
日本ヒルズだけ着る前あまりと人が住んでい
今でも行けますん
持った
香ってであるいうと地形があって面白い場所だったりして
それがまあ再開発によってまあコッキーナビルがあって
人がすごく集まり小山市いろんなことが起こってはいるんですけれども
例えば街の雰囲気がねーなー
いくらこのような形です
とか
そこがすごく高級化してしまって
夕日と氷デーでそこを
動いているひとつのパン
あってしまったりとか
やっぱそういう持ちが大きく変化することに対して僕自身はちょっとしたいが関係を
感じるようになっています
その時にまあ
出会った物質はパートっ
まあそんなことを考えて学生時代少しているとニューヨーク位
双方というところがあると思うんですけれども
双方って今中と高級ブティックとか
高い
じゃないっ
世界の並ぶすごくコマーシャル場所
まあ
家賃が入っておりますとして有名になるんですもうもともと
情報ってある終始案が悪かったとか
はそんな人で唯一かかる場所1960年代くらいです
その頃やっそういう所って館林んが13
当時は感じたと言われる人たちはおっきな割と好きな場所で
キング政策もできたりとかしてチームらしく心地がありましょう昔からですって
やっぱりそんな8日に思っている人か
そういう場所に8ある人たちが降って
アトリエを作ったりとか
あるいは何か自分たちが暮らしていけるように
レストランライナー
そこでご飯とも提供していきながらまあ生活をしたりしてい
すると今度そこにはいつだって全部面白いことをやっている人たちがいるとそこに
まあ
ブーバー4泊ちょっちゅちゅっ
その場所を価値が上がっていくということをご理解しますです
そういう時にまあきゃんっ
とか
ハート星言われるほどが生まれたりして
がそういうコミュニティがすごく面白いなと思うんですけれども判明
ほんとそういう場所が中国されすぎると
さらに人が集まっていて
でどうせに関わりしてません
追ってよくにおいてくる人が大きいアダルト
ok うちの風ゲーム出されるか
どんなでも安い now
それによって
最終的にそこにもともと繊維な人です
最初に面白いなと思って
永長後輩なくなってしまって出ていく理由
まあそういうことでという返しがいろんなところで起こっていると思うんですけれども
桑抱くそういうアーティスト
本当に関わる人たちがあっ
もともと勝ちのなかっとお前ていたところに活用にいらして行動体がすごく面白いと
思って
相続建築を勉強していた頃に
喜納開発をしていくことがだけじゃないんじゃないよなっていうような思い
あのアートに注目していきます
注ぐときにこの写真何かなって思いですか
多いと思うわれ
僕はちょっと今日にすることに
う
希望を冠したというかちょっと違うところに住んでいたいなぁ
そういう最下位格みたいところですとか大きな建築を出征することではないような所に
自分の身を置いてみたい
そのきっかけというのはなんか後にあるんじゃないかなーと思って
山口県に移り住んで裏口系で
まあ高強度本当にかしてるぜ
たと言われるこれで働く
まあ2働き始めているから住んでた芸がここないんですね
この a 級のは山口市の割と街中にありまして
思いやり点からいいぐらいやってもいいですか
アクセスもすごく良い場所にあります
まあここ入社のかというとどうな思想の
やっぱりするアートに関わる仕事応じていたゆえ神と一緒にシェアして進んでたら
言えるわけですね
まあその当時ちょうど医専6年くらい
10年以上前になるんですけどもうここをとモーター神田梨絵として僕らわー
まっすんでいたんですけどそれって
経営だったり人で
いろんな人が集まってくるようになったんですねでは僕らの軍人は
問題ないのか
なんかこの作りあに関わっている人はすごくを送ってそういう人たちがまあ山口の不妊
くるとやっぱりみんな若くて他には持っていなかったので
ホテルに終わるよりはなんとなく家に泊まってくるということが多くて
そうやって人が泊まりに来れてですね台か来たら
宴会や号とかパーティー野郎とかってことによって
一問英答
単純にスってのみかんいたことをやってたんですね
ただそういうときまあどこか違うところから来た人って
いうとまあそういう人たち2人を中心して
その種の例えば自分の活動を紹介するとか
こういう作品を作っ天暦話をしたりするということがどんどん起こってい
そういう場所にはここはもう本当に街中の
物に住宅地の中には音声倍の住宅地の中にある上だって
近所の人だったりとか僕らのルールでいいですとか割とまぁ最初に近い子達が
つまり足が
もともと別に字関係ない別には利賀スキーとかデブない人も
この家が雨の前にあっ
子供が結構カバで遊んでそのままお家に入ってくれることがあったりです
崩れの風がだんだん第家に行こう
なんかー
あっほどもを配して近づいてくれって事が起こっていったんです
そうしているとあのまぁ最初の子供学校ない頃はネットワーク
まぁ大人が違って
話をしているところです男性はまた少しずつ変わって
こういうところでまぁグランドにしたかった例えばこれ
coward 煌1日だけ作ってそこで飲み会をしようということになった
けどまぁコレ法律的には
本当はダメなことなんで
ダメなことだったにもあのせなんかそういうタイプちょっとセットするとみんな全然
日常とちょっとだけ違う空間で違う感覚で話ができたんですよ
と思うんですね
ただで僕らが曲の時は金銀の人に
ちん子だけこういうタイプ作ろうと思うと一緒にどんなに食べたりし
を楽しみましょうということで眉人もいい
もちろん前から苦情が来ることもで区台風どこが来たら負0
そうではないに意外と交流にころって
ルールに縛られなければ
教える方こってぃんまいと思います
こんな感じで越冬
自分たちの家を少しだけ食べましてい
手前の代わりに増やしていくとか
ここが縁側あったんですね縁側がリラック猫の感じで見てもらうと分かる
道まあなんとなく極楽へを拡張自体がある丁寧なと
子どもたちの結構員が入って
俺が部分というと人が出会う場所だったです
そんなところで
別に特に後をやろうとかっていうわけじゃなくって面白いやつきたから一緒に話を
しようみたいなパルスでコミュニケーションを取れる場所でした
ここがからもともと個人の依頼です
とはいえあの常に人が集まる場所だったので
公共施設ではないけれども飯山皇居
犯行教区簡単だなということを何段も暗いしてしていく
と言われるんですね
そういう判断も今日空間で
面白いところが大きな号教室って
できないようすごく時間がかかるようなことを
イオンということを
でもだけど個人の場所ではない単純に個人結んでるだけ
そこが引っ越し開かれている
おっと違う形でちょっとだけを契約とかっ
それは何かあ
新しい形の
文議員があり方
人のまーすまいなたつまり方にの可能性があるじゃくんっていうふうに思っていました
こんな稼働してですね
まぁこんな感じで割と人が集まって一緒に映画を見たりとか
建コレまあゆすりんがいいんですけどといえば共作で見たいとかそんなことをやって
まいります
縁側でバーベキューしなかった
ここハンクス50ようでこれは双方約差し上げ
おいしいご飯を出しておい重要になるかっ
結局うんちくよりは
美味しいものを食べる
そういう場所をしやすいすごく重要で常にごはんについて来て
それでまあちょっとした収益をあげるって事思ってない
こんな粒続けていくと
ある日の
g 友人なんですけど一人が看板を作っていったんですね
お前街といえ場所にある
名前まちハートセンターという看板悪い友人が作って玄関目的
だんだんこの場所か毎晩チャーセンターの頭某所とってマックと呼ばれるようになって
本は本当に計ミンとかいう支援が集まりましたとたまりここを訪れてくる人が現れまし
たですつまり
皇居そういうアクセになってきたらしいになる
編んだり選んだけれども人がやってくるよ
とやってなくが助けることで
その場所性質が少しずつ変わっていったりとかして僕らもここってどうか
&センターの拡張と思って今度自分たちでいろんな助成金を奪ったりですとか
少しお金を獲得してあるプロジェクト
展覧会みたいなものを立ち上げたりをしてい
そして5分など日本が違う公共性を獲得していくこと
無事の金利の子供がいパイカルで子供に向けた学校ではできないことをまあ僕らも遊び
の一杯としてやろうということで
夏休みとか子供もう日まで僕らも土日休みの仕事だから結構芸術家峰
ia 時間が来そういう時に抱く子どもと地と
電動ドリルをやってみたいとかこういうワークショップをした
をしていました
まぁこんな感じのことを言って公共施設回やりづらいんですけれどもうそれをな違う
フィルターである好況だからこそできるという形で
こんなことを
していましたので
僕自身はずっといろんな規模の秋フェスティバルですか
ご意見欄快感に変わっているんですけれども今てにやっぱりその年
人が生きる場所時 lo
どうやって自分で想像している
ありがとうへ発展していけるのかということをすごく
アーティストたち
と物事をものを作っている人たちから学んでまあそれを何巻原始的な方法はないかなと
いうふうにこれ
あのーそれでもう一度皆さんの一方問いかけたいなと思うことっていうか
まああととかそういう想像っていうのは何か新しい価値をしたりですとか
同時にまあ既存の価値観を疑う家すくねえもあるんじゃないか
いう多いですね
例えばくのって言うとすごくよくできたフォーマットだと思うんです
みんなですって
なんかいい話っぽい歌詞をして客さんがみんなが感動するかもしれない
みんなが完了するともしかしたら危険なことがあります
例えばのシートが入ってみんなが感動するところからできたと言う
ほしいっ
というようなことを疑っていることって
社会の中でこういうマートだったり重い役割だと思う
それは何か人の創造性を支援して
人に独自のコミュニティをつくって生きる力を与えてくれる
と思いますね
国語力を持っているのですねまぁこれからもう2011年後日本の人口って
消費者委を買っていてこれから少子高齢化といわれる社会になっていくと思う
そういう時に
今宴抜く力例えば欲しいっ
年後ようで
行っちゃうところです
まあそういう入って行った時にでもそれぞれがもちょっとした創造ステップ誰でも持っ
ている
創造共有創造性おりまして
自分自身自分なりにぐらいかということをできていく人が少しずつ増えていくと社会
って
豊かで多様なものになっていくのか
いうふうに思ってマークが少し染みだしたがそれ超えておりました
けどを
まあ北海を取るんですけれども
こんな活動って何してるのかなと思ったら
みんなやっぱりこういうことをそれぞれに考えていけたらいいなというふうに思います
どこでどういうです
あるいは暮らしていくようかということを
それぞれが政府に対して遠いて生きる社会
行くと良いと思いながらトイレしれないと思い
[拍手]